My absolute lymphocytes is a different person, was 1,500, then 1368, in 2024, in September,
was 1053. Is that me? My immune system is going down. My white blood cell count is 5.4.
The last test, the other numbers are good. No, it doesn't.
If your immune system is dropping, you know, to say immune system, there's many components of the
immune system, not just your white blood cells, but when you're concerned about a suppressed
immune system, you're going to see a decrease in white blood cell count. There can be multiple reasons
for that long-term cancer. It can be one of them. Long-term viral infection can be another one.
There can be, you know, there's lots of different reasons immune deficiency diseases can factor
into that too. But if your white blood cell count is 5.4, that's not an issue. And your lymphocyte
and your neutrophil, your differential count is going to vary depending on what's going on at that
specific time. So again, lymphocytes are going to be elevated. If the person has an infection,
that's more apt to be viral. Neutrophils are going to be elevated. The person has an infection
that's more apt to be bacterial. But your absolute counts are going to vary from time to time.
And, you know, we all have different things that we're fighting off at different times that we don't
have full or half infections in the bowel.